last time on 30-minute thesis
i discussed all the interesting ways in
which sir roger penrose's conformal
cyclic cosmology could revolutionize our
understanding of cosmology and even the
origin of the universe but i neglected
to mention all the ways that sir roger
could be wrong and ways that we could
prove him wrong would actually be almost
as enticing as if his theory is right
this video explains the experimental
techniques my colleagues and i are
working on to explore ways to not prove
him right but prove him wrong come along
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
so we built bicep we took it to
antarctica we measured the imprimatur of
the early universe here's a picture from
the washington post which shows kind of
this cartoon of an explosion being
the process of inflation producing a
background of gravitational waves which
shake up and reverberate the cosmic
microwave backgrounds last scattering
surface imprinting upon it the
imprimatur of inflation namely
inflation occurs then the universe will
have a background of tensor modes
gravitational waves like a gas suffusing
the entire universe it will exist at 380
000 years after the big bang it will
cause a twisting curling pattern of
microwaves called b mode polarization
that is observable today and that's what
we set out to do
how does it work well bicep and all
these polarimeters detect the
polarization one of the properties of
light that is most remarkable is that it
is possible for the wave of
electromagnetic radiation to oscillate
preferentially along one axis that's
called linear polarization
so unpolarized light say from the sun
can come and bounce off the ocean
surface as it does here in la jolla
quite frequently and there you can see
some glare from reflections off the sea
surface and it can become polarized and
that polarization is due to suppression
of one of the two linear polarization
modes then with a polarimeter namely
your eyes
with a tiny lens and a retina detector
replacing a ccd camera
you can use this polarizing sunglasses
pair to modulate and subtract out one of
the two polarization modes thus giving
you glare-free vision
so that's a simple polarimeter here's an
illustration from wayne who a colleague
and friend of mine at university of
chicago that shows how matter and light
can interact producing a polarized
signal from an initially unpolarized
signal
and that will result in b modes if the
universe possesses gravitational wave
energy at the time of last scanner
so we built bicep 2 we built bicep one
took it down to the south pole in 2005.
the south pole is the dead center of
antarctica so getting to antarctica is
quite a journey but the actual uh
destination at the south pole is quite
striking
and all the more so for it having been
the site in which we detected at least
the claimed detection for the first time
falsifying conformal cyclic cosmology
the uh the quasi-steady state theory and
also the bouncing bombs now of course we
all know that my book is titled losing
the nobel prize not winning the nobel
prize so despite making this
announcement which was exactly the image
predicted and shown from the washington
post here we discovered the exact real
data signal shown here this is not a
simulation this b mode polarization map
led to
many many
headlines around the world including the
newspaper of record that is the san
diego union tribune of course but also
in this new york times you should see it
above the fold as they say even made the
economist made it onto cnn
it was a media storm we had a viral
videos with 3 million views on youtube
andre linde being informed that we've
detected the earliest evidence for
inflationary cosmology
we also pertinent to sir roger penrose
claimed by him to have detected what are
known as hawking points i'll have more
to say about that in a future video
suffice it to say that this evidence has
also kind of gone away
but it's interesting to note the
conclusions on that very day that famous
day in in 2014 when we made the
announcement at harvard center for
astrophysics
the
announcement went out all around the
world not only that everybody was going
to win nobel prizes for all
but that we had now
shown
evidence for the first time for the
multiverse here's a article written by
my good friend and pass gas max tag mark
good morning inflation hello multiverse
so again if you detect primordial waves
of gravity then you would have reason to
have credit credulity in the
inflationary universe's origin if
inflation took place you have reason to
think that the multiverse is true so the
stakes could not be higher and of course
as i've talked about in previous
episodes uh and my talks at google and
my tedx talk etc the universe is not so
kind always and we couldn't stop
thinking about that cosmic interstellar
dust and eventually it all went down to
dust eden sank to dust as i talk about
losing the nobel prize so the universe
isn't this pristine looking glass uh
clear looking glass that you can see all
the way back to the origin of the
universe instead it's quite smoggy so
nothing gold can stay nobel laureate
robert frost alpined uh that eden sank
to grief and nothing gold could stay so
the nobel prize didn't stay at least for
me and probably best that it didn't
given my criticisms of it
but another person who was nominated for
the nobel prize
and yet did not win it as mahatma gandhi
who invoked in us a
clear call a clarion call that the
seeker after truth should be humbler
than the dust the world crushes the dust
under its feet but the seeker after
truth
should so humble himself that even the
dust could crush him only then and not
until then will he have a glimpse of
truth now this is in his book or his
poems and writings on experiments with
truth now i'm an experimental
cosmologist so what do we do we need to
build a new experiment that can see dust
and see the cosmic microwave background
b-mode polarization signals if they
exist subtract the dust from the total
signal and what is left should be the
pristine evidence that might invalidate
conformal cyclic cosmology bouncing
cosmology and of course the
quasi-steady-state cosmology so we're
doing that the simon's observatory uh
with uh which i lead with my colleagues
suzanne stags adrian lee and mark devlin
we are building this observatory with
our students colleagues and friends
partners around the world 300 strong
building an amazing observatory in the
atacama desert of northern chile
so how do you get rid of the dust well
you just suck it up you build a giant
space sucker
no we're not doing that we're actually
building an experiment that's capable of
seeing both the small scale fluctuations
in the microwave background that are
indicative of the formation of galaxies
the evolution of dark energy if that
takes place
the distribution of dark matter but also
measuring
the b mode polarization at large angular
scales just like bicep and bicep two but
with multiple frequencies and i should
say the bicep team is also going about
their business and what's known as a
bicep array building multi-frequency
multi-polarization sensitive detectors
i will produce a video about how these
experiments work but for now i'll just
remind you that we're going after these
primordial b modes which will occur if
they exist if inflation took place if
the multiverse is true they will exist
at large scales and that will allow us
to falsify these competitive models that
don't feature this primordial hyper
expansion faster than the speed of light
as we've talked about in previous videos
about inflation the inflation crash
course for example we'll have three
small aperture telescopes in the simon's
observatory that will allow us to see in
six different frequency channels
several to guard against dust and
several to measure uh synchrotron
radiation which is a lower frequency
phenomenon and then several to measure
the cmb signals alone if inflation took
place these primordial b modes would be
produced
so here in san diego we're building the
birthday present that maybe perhaps sir
roger would not be so happy to receive
and shown here my students and postdocs
and collaborators working on one of the
small aperture telescopes that will be
one of the first to deploy to our site
in chile
here's a schematic of it uh shown here
produced by my
outstanding postdoc dr nicolas
galitsky the simon's observatory uses
these focal planes uh designed and
optimized by suzanne staggs who's our
spokesperson at princeton university
these are magical devices that work at
100 milli degrees above
zero kelvin so 0.1 kelvin
colder by far than interstellar space
and she's assembled these and packaged
these with her teammates to make the
most sensitive cosmic microwave
background focal planes ever devised we
made great progress we poured down
foundations and built a site with our
own concrete delivered from far away
so where does this leave us can we ever
prove
that inflation took place no we can't
can we ever prove that the universe has
eons or cycles or bounces etc no but we
can falsify these models if they're not
correct and if inflation is correct so
it's kind of different it's a different
situation to be in than many other tests
that we've talked about on this channel
many other observations we can prove
inflation's competitors we can prove
them wrong but we can't necessarily
prove inflation right i've talked about
in my video the faith of a physicist
that i don't believe in gravity and
talked about notions of belief versus
evidence here's a quote from my friend
paul davies the multiverse which is part
of concomitant hand-in-hand with
inflation may be dressed up in
scientific language but it requires the
same leap of faith as a belief and an
unseen creator
[Music]
the last thing i'll say is that the
universe of sir roger penrose deals with
this very very vexing problem of entropy
that we talked about in my video
cracking the cosmic egg that video
discussed the origin of entropy in a low
entropy state and how it could then
evolve to higher and higher entropy and
not have to make use of an imposition by
fiat as many call what's known as the
past hypothesis many physicists find
that distasteful as eating some of these
eggs shown in these egg cracking
failures but of course sir roger was one
of the first to point this out 30 years
ago almost that the universe evolving to
higher and higher entropy today meant
that it must have been an
extraordinarily low entropy in the deep
deep past
and so the uh statement by paul
steinhardt shown here from his
scientific american article shows that
the number of inflationary models that
actually work and produce a low entropy
state start to the universe are
exceptionally low almost so low as to
require the imposition by fiat now you
could say fiat is kind of like uh the
latin translation the motto of the
university of california where i am fiat
lux let there be light means that's what
god said so is this somehow again
another kind of
shout out to religion and that the past
hypothesis specifies by fiat the
imposition of low entropy conditions i'm
not going to talk much about religion on
this channel in these videos however it
is interesting to note that this is
exceptionally rare and again it's
another uncomfortable truth an
inconvenient truth as nobel laureate al
gore would say so is there a last word
from sir roger does he have any hope of
having a successful happy
90th birthday and beyond
well he visited me here not too long ago
at uc san diego here he is not far from
where the small aperture telescope that
i just showed is being assembled this is
right before
the global pandemic erupted but i have
great high hopes that not necessarily
will we see the imprimatur of what he
calls these hawking points which are the
remnants of black holes that somehow
make it through
the big bang of one universe into the
big bang of another universe he claims
to have detected evidence for this
researchers don't uh suggest with very
high likelihood any sufficient evidence
to claim detection of hawking points as
sir roger and his colleagues have
asserted i think the jury is still out
we'd like to get more data on this it
doesn't look good right now for hawking
points but that doesn't mean that
conformal cyclic cosmology is falsified
a better test would be a detection of
primordial gravitational waves but again
that requires that inflation took place
so in conclusion we have many different
reasons to suspect that the universe has
peculiar properties properties that cry
out for explanation
whether those explanations come from a
universe that had a cyclical eon-like
behavior of sir roger penrose or wit
whether it had an eternal multiverse
behavior of lindae and guth and others
or whether it expands and collapses in a
bouncing scenario that has yet to be
seen but the key point is this is not
the end
it is not even the beginning of the end
but it is perhaps the end of the
beginning so i wish to roger penrose a
happy 90th birthday here's to many
miller birthday celebrated together and
never stop searching for now brian
keating chancellor distinguished
professor of physics at the university
of california and co-director
of the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination thanking you for going into
the impossible
[Music]
if you enjoyed this video you definitely
want to check out this playlist with
my cosmology friends talking about the
origin and evolution of the universe
and if you're interested in a deep dive
in the multiverse wormholes and other
exotic phenomena click here and hear my
conversation with juan maldasena of the
institute for advanced study enjoy and
don't forget to subscribe for more
amazing content